welcome to the macmillan report
i'm marilyn wilkes your host and our
guest is frank griffel
a professor of islamic studies at yale
university
professor griffel teaches courses on the
intellectual history of islam
its theology and the way islamic
thinkers react to western modernity
he is published widely in the fields of
islamic theology
arab and islamic philosophy islamic law
and muslim intellectual history today
we'll talk with professor griffel
about his new book al ghazali's
philosophical theology
welcome professor griffel glad to be
here marilyn
so let's start with al ghazali who is he
and then give us an
overview of your book al-hazali is
one of the most important theologians
and overall thinkers in the islamic
world
he's also probably the one author of
classical islam who is most widely read
today
and he was most widely read all through
the centuries that he had lived
he lived at the turn to the 12th century
which was in europe just the end of the
dark ages
yet in the islamic world it was a time
of very
lively intellectual activity both in the
natural sciences
in philosophy as well in theology okay
and what led you to write this book what
was your inspiration
well i've been fascinated with
al-ghazali for
very many years and two reasons
first of all his importance as an
islamic author
a muslim theologian who really
formulated
to a large degree what was at least for
many centuries regarded as islamic
orthodoxy
for me it was very important at one
point in my life to understand what
islam is
its intellectual history and at one
point
i decided understanding al-ghazali helps
me a lot
in doing so so it is importance that
triggered me there was a second aspect
that i was also very much interested in
which
triggered mostly my interest in in the
book that i just wrote
and that was his position as one might
say an
angle point between what is the
aristotelian
tradition in islam something that we
call falsafa
philosophy in islam and islamic theology
he has often been regarded as the
thinker
who somewhat fought
islamic philosophy or philosophy arabic
philosophy within islam
and defeated it and from the very moment
i started reading him
i thought that this is not entirely
right and i
digged after this and the fruit of it is
the book that i just wrote
okay and let's talk a little bit about
how you did your research what was your
methodology
well when you do intellectual history
you basically read books
you go to the library you check out
books you read them once you read them
twice
and very often you read passages 10
times before you really get
what these passages mean in this case of
of writing about al-ghazali i was
surprised to what extent actually i also
had to deal with manuscripts
because we think that was such an
important author the manuscripts which
have of course preserved his works to us
in the modern period which were written
in the middle ages
and then later on that they have now all
been turned into printed books
but that was not the case there was
still a great number of texts in the
case of al-ghazali that still
were only in manuscripts and not yet
printed
and there was also the issue that many
of the prints that we were dealing with
were entirely reliable so i actually
worked a lot with manuscripts
particularly in european libraries but
also in libraries in the middle east
okay and how does your research differ
from the traditional views on al ghazali
i would say the position that i have
taken with regard to al-razali
is somewhat part of a larger
re-evaluation
of the philosophical tradition in islam
the classical view
that was put forward by early
or early great scholars in the field of
islamic scholar in islamic studies
who worked mostly at the beginning of
the 20th century
and this view was then also shared by
arab and muslim thinkers was
that islamic philosophy in islam arabic
philosophy
which was pursued in islam was very
lively
and very active until a certain point in
time
when the culture somewhat has given up
this activity
and the prejudice was that
and in this case an occupation more with
religious literature particularly where
the quran actually has replaced
uh the rationalist inquiry of the
philosophers
by now we think that this is only half
of the story
it is true that there was a lively
thriving of
philosophy of the tradition of greek
philosophy within islam
but it is also true that at one point
this tradition
was turned over so to speak from the
philosophical discourse to the
theological discourse
and my position is that al-ghazali
actually took a very important
position in this turning of
philosophy into what we call kalam
literature which is
rationalist theological literature
the traditionalist view however is
totally different by basically saying
that
al-azali destroyed the tradition of
falzafa
he in fact wrote a very important book
which criticizes
many teachings of the arabic
philosophers most importantly amongst
them
the philosopher ivan sina known in the
west is avicenna
and this particular book wasn't very
deeply studied
one read the beginning one read the end
and draw from it the conclusion
that it was an all-out refutation
of the philosophical tradition which it
clearly wasn't
in fact it was one part and one parcel
one might say
of the earth of al-ghazali which was to
some degree
criticizing philosophical tradition yet
on the other hand also
integrating much of what he does not
criticize
in this case into the islamic
theological discourse
okay and what conclusions do you reach
in your book
a number of conclusions the book is
actually mostly concerned with
al-ghazali's life also
with al-ghazali's students and then
i focus on what is his cosmology okay
let me go through them one by one
with his life i was surprised to see how
how little serious work has been done in
the past decades on his life
particularly
since two new important sources have
come up
in this case his letters uh his persian
letters which were edited
in the 1950s and have not yet had much
impact
on the secondary literature about his
life despite the fact that they offer
a huge amount of insight about what he
was doing about particular how he felt
what he was doing secondly his
students one of the problems that
scholars who were dealing with the life
of al ghazali and his works were always
confronted with
is that his works are far from being
unambiguous
sometimes in fact he argues in favor of
a certain position
yet in another book he might actually
take a position that is opposed to that
and my strategy was to look in this case
closely
into how his students or his early
followers write about him
and write about his teachings to
basically find out how did they think
what he truly taught and from there did
use in a matter of speaking
how he communicated with his students
what he told his students are his in a
matter of speaking
true teachings and what are the one that
he might have taken
at one point in his life or in this case
how
he might in fact reconcile two positions
that initially seem to be contradictory
and this is actually the main part of
the book this is uh the third part on
cosmology
now first i should probably explain what
cosmology is yes cosmology means
uh how the world any theory that refers
to
how the world is constructed in this
particular case we might talk about our
cosmology for instance
that most of us believe in the existence
of a big bang we are convinced actually
that there was something like a big bang
that from then on the universe spread
and from then on we have for instance
the
development of quarks of neutrinos
of atoms of molecules out of molecules
we have bodies
bodies react in a certain way to cause a
laws
etc etc this is what we call cosmology
how actually the universe is constructed
for medieval thinkers this is closely
this subject is closely connected to how
god
responds or reacts or in this case acts
upon
his creation the world is of course
regarded as god's creation
and here is particularly important how
does god create
that is the interesting question there
and there has been developed a
particular islamic view i might say
which we refer to as
occasionalism which by and large and i
make it short
simply teaches that god creates
every object and every in every moment
anew
so we might talk we might think about it
as if god as if this world would be like
a film
where we have frame after frame after
frame after film and
each frame in this case each moment in
itself is newly created
that is one view and then there is the
other view which is i would say probably
uh more closer to our current
understanding because
it comes from the work of aristotle
particular that
there are causal laws that determine how
things actually react to one another in
this world and that this causes laws of
of course our god's creation
and that matter and all these things are
also quotes creation
and that in a matter of speaking god
creates by means
of these causal laws
so far before i actually finished my
book one might say or before i
came to the to the main conclusion of my
book people in our field were divided
in saying that al razali was either one
who was totally in favor of the
so-called occasionalist view
where god creates everything in every
moment anew
or in favor of the view that god uses
so-called secondary causality
god employs causal chains of
of effects and of courses and effects in
order to
achieve the goals that he actually
wants to achieve in this case aims to
achieve
what i came to conclude is that
al-ghazali in this case held both views
he thought that these two views although
they seem to be contradictory
for him they were not they would express
the same kind of cosmology
for him it was most important to
acknowledge that god is the creator of
everything in this world
be it either in the way that he creates
everything in every moment or new
or be it in the on the other hand as the
starting point
of all the cause of change that we
actually do
see unfolding in this world okay
and lastly what was the most surprising
thing you found in doing research for
your book well two things i think
um first of all when i uh when i
uh looked into his life in particular
when i looked into his letters
and uh what he writes about his own life
i found out that he was actually born
at a date different from what we
currently have in all our dictionaries
and in all our encyclopedias about him
that of course is only a small matter
the other thing that
fascinated me is that al-ghazali
thought about sciences in a very very
modern way
and that was certainly even a surprise
to me but it was probably more a
surprise to other people who always
thought that
al hazali was one of the people who had
destroyed the sciences in islam
i think nothing is further from the
truth in fact he is someone who
supported the sciences who've wanted to
find the cosmology
that actually leads to first of all
acknowledging god as the creator of the
world but
also in helping scientists to pursue the
sciences
so in a nutshell one might say he
thought
in his cosmology of course which did not
have the big bang but if we would
translate
his cosmology to the big bang as god as
the creator of the big bang
god created the big bang and from that
moment on
all the causes and effects that have
unfolded since then with necessity
are mediated god's creation in this case
god deliberately chose one might say how
to create the big bang and everything
that has happened since then
is in this case a causal effect of this
one event
that god actually put into this world
which i thought was a very fitting way
for a theologian to think about this
universe
very good thank you very much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your research
my pleasure for more information about
professor griffel and his work
please visit our website at yale.edu
backslash macmillan report
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
whitney and betty mcmillan center
for international and area studies at
yale
you